bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france qu'est ce qui a poussé à
l'ouverture de cette commission
parlementaire que reproche-t-on au
gouvernement brésilien
c'est pas très difficile à savoir
puisque le les services de la présidence
la casa cdo a fait elle-même une liste
des points sur lesquels les sénateurs
pourraient chatouiller le président ils
ont ils ont fait une liste de 23
manquement grave que le prudent le
président s'est rendu coupable au cours
depuis le début de la poudre de la crise
qui vont du refus des vaccins dont vous
venez de parler à des tas de d'occasion
cours desquelles il est sorti sans
masque il a poussé les gens à sortir son
masque saboter les campagnes qui était
fait une vaccination est faite par les
états tous d'ici les propres services de
la présidence trou 23 raison de l'accusé
si vraiment il a une ardoise changé
quelles conséquences justement fait la
commission d'en tête peut-elle avoir sur
la stratégie de d'ailleurs molson arrow
face à l'épidémie
constitutionnellement cela l'institution
qui peut renverser le président c'est à
dire faire un des pitchouns à toi une
destitution c'est le sénat et donc si le
sénat décide qu'il est coupable
il faut d'abord que la chambre des
députés le mettre en accusation ce n'est
parfait et il pourrait potentiellement
le faire ils ont déjà fait deux fois vu
le président colom années 90 et dilma
rousseff en 2016 mais je pense pas que
ce soit très sérieux en fait je pense
que legault le groupement de partis qui
a appuyé
bodjona qui continue à appuyer qui vient
de prendre le contrôle du sénat
probablement fait plutôt monter les
enchères
c'est dire s'il agite la menace l'eau
près du président pour obtenir encore
plus de ministère plus de crédits plus
de postes donc je pense que c'est
vraiment un moyen de renforcer leur
propre pouvoir ou détriment celui du
président et comme je le demandais par
rapport à la stratégie de diabolo
d'euros contre phase aller à la pandémie
est ce que ça peut changer à la donne si
assez difficile à savoir ce que vous
serez polir dix ans qu'il a eue
deux stratégies imprévisible c'est à
dire qu'ils changent constamment
d'altitude quand il sent vraiment que la
menace se rapproche
il fait un certain nombre de concessions
mais dans l'ensemble il nous fait qu'est
ce qui lui passe par la tête et plus
récemment il a commencé de nouveau agité
la menace d'un coup d'état militaire qui
est probablement là aussi du bluff
puisque l'armée apparemment d'après
retrait décidé à suivre
oui il serait prêt à envoyer l'armée
pour mettre un terme au confinement
locaux on est ce que c'est sérieux c'est
vraiment sérieux avec géo bosna le milan
n'a le pouvoir mais c'est quand même
tout à fait étrange ce serait le seul
pays au monde qui emploient l'armée
non pas pour renforcer le confinement
mais pour le supprimer vous faites ça
fait partie là aussi doté d'une querelle
politique qu'il a avec les gouverneurs
des états et notamment le l'état de sang
parle qui est le plus gros états de la
fédération et 40 millions d'habitants et
dont le gouverneur qui mène une
politique assez active contre le
coronavirus avec le confinement en
produisant des vaccins dans la
principale institution médicale le sang
parle fait de l'ombre au président de
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il souhaite
contrecarrer la politique des états qui
luttent beaucoup plus sérieusement
contre le golf et cette commission
denquête pourquoi sfr intervient
maintenant l'élection présidentielle qui
se profile en 2022 vous pensez que c'est
l'une des raisons
oui au parquet puis faire monter les
enchères comme je disais il espère
obtenir encore plus davantage du
président en le prenant un peu à la
gorge et donc une zone où si je place
probablement pour l'élection qui vient
merci j'avais dans les attendait dans le
reportage parler de scouts nice il faut
savoir que l'argentine vient de
l'accepter c'est peut-être aussi une des
raisons c'est peut-être un peu vexé que
l'argentine accepte tout niké donc le
brésil le refuge pour l'instant merci
beaucoup à vous hervé théry je rappelle
que vous êtes géographe professeur à
l'université de sao paulo